the 1920s women moved out of their
parents house and actually got an
apartment and worked and this is
actually when you see the birth rate
declining
um arguably and you know birth growth
controls part of it but one of the
biggest factors of women not reproducing
is spending their primary reproductive
years working and partying instead of
having children okay
um now women have a lot more choice we
get to choose who gets sex we get to
choose
who we date and marry right now how do
women pick do we do we look for things
like character so there's a survey by
change research that bound over 50
percent of women under 35 of you
listening to The Joe Rogan Experience as
a major dating red flag this sentiment
aligns with liberal Trends among younger
women with other red flags including
support for Maga belief in a binary
gender system and saying all lives
matter the economic Outlook among
respondents was pessimistic and most
expressed little confidence in achieving
financial goals despite their concerns
young people are politically active with
79 intending to vote in the 2024
election favoring Biden over Trump men
showed a preference for Ron DeSantis
podcast consumption is common among 36
percent of men with The Joe Rogan
Experience being a popular choice the
impact of these Trends on The Dating
Market remains uncertain okay so let me
um Let me let me dive into this so
instead of women asking about
I don't know things that matter like
their character integrity
I don't know religion I'd say that's
important Family Values
it's do you watch Joe Rogan
and guys this is the thing I I'm not
even saying this to hate women to
on women I'm saying this to point out
that women we just don't make good
decisions we just don't there's a reason
we have phrases like Daddy Issues like
these things don't just come out of
nowhere there's a reason that you see
women kind of go cuckoo over time you
see the Jennifer Aniston's the Courtney
Cox's of the world we just kind of go a
little bit nutty who when women lead
relationships they kind of go a little
crazy too you know and and now we have
women picking husbands boyfriends
baby fathers based on if they listen to
Joe Rogan or not and I'm going to
predict that women will still sleep with
the more conservative guys
that's my prediction because women hate
these liberal men they really do